My house is like a museum open to
the Latin American world. I think there will be
some tender pieces of music. The
collection consists of LPs
that we will have about 50 million pesos,
45-revolution records, 78-revolution records,
40,000 CDs.
Music transports me to places
that  almost nothing transports me it is a
drug for me
my name is alejandro a ferrell eta better
known as gladys palma and I am a
collector of Latin music of
all time I have always had
Latin America very close to me my father
worked a lot there my mother was from
Panama and  He has started
listening to this type of music since he
was a child when he was 4 or 5 years old.
I started collecting when I
lived in Panama for a year when I was 18.
Well, here in the collection we have
music from practically all the countries
of Latin America.
We are really going to complete the best.  of
the best of Latin music because I believe
that everyone has the right to
access all of this, not just a few, I believe
that  You have to delve much deeper into the
roots of this music to understand the
number of groups that there have been of the
chachachá, the boogaloo or the mambo you go
deeper and deeper and
you really come to realize what it
means and the importance that it has,
I don't  I do this for myself, all of
this collection, my idea is to share it
with the whole world and my desire has been to be
able to deliver this
collection tomorrow to an institution to be able to
make it available to a public
anyone who can come here or
wherever they go  finish the collection and be
able to express all of this,
each record here has a
story and has a peculiarity
Latin America is a range of music is
that it is that I discover every day I
discover and I am surprised no I dedicate myself
to this basically for  passion it gives me
great pleasure to be able to spread this and
this is the world of gladys palma
[Music]